hello everyone and welcome back to the
line' are a series of 1991 featuring
Vasiliy even shook this is round 12 of
the tournament so only one more round
left after this game this game event is
playing against the Boris Gelfand and
going into this tournament get fun had a
rating of 2700 here was rated number 3
in the world vastly wuntch was rated
number 4 only 5 points well lower than
Boris Gelfand 20 695 so it's it's
definitely a very interesting game the
tournament is almost over so there are
bound to be more mistakes and well
everybody wants to grab that last point
so let's see this game a lot of people
say that this entire game is home
preparation by Yvonne Chuck but I don't
think so because of one move that
gelfand played but maybe maybe
girlfriend was famous for playing this
move in the groom felt so maybe some of
you know more but let's see the game if
I took out the white pieces and he plays
d4 Knight to f6
we have c4 c6 Knight to f3 Bishop to g7
now g3 get from castles bishop - G - d5
transposing into the groom fell defense
we have castles the d captures on c4 and
now Knight to a 3 and here a lot of
moves are possible for forget fund for
example Knight to c6 c5 c6 any number of
moves but Geffen decided to play c3 now
I'm not really familiar with this move
so this is the reason why I don't think
that this was a avengers home
preparation be captures and c3 was
played by one choke c5 III Knight to c6
Queen to e2 and Queen to a5 now adding
pressure to this knight on a 3 and also
attacking this c3 pawn so eventual
defense this Bishop to b2 Knight to
Knight to d5 now adding more pressure to
the c3 pawn and rook a to c1 eventually
defends the pawn and here well again a
lot of moves are possible for black
well you can capture on d4 probably the
best move would be to develop this
bishop all the way to g4 and gain even
more development but Griffin played b6
he wants to develop this bishop on b7 or
maybe even play Bishop to a6 but this is
a bit too adventurous if I choke
immediately plays Knight to d2 preparing
a moves like Knight to b3 or Knight to
c4 would a temple on the Queen on a5 and
also opening up this bishops diagonal so
now this Bishop is slicing all the way
well this knight on d5 is now under
attack if it moves this knight on c6 is
under attack and well that rook on a 8
it doesn't really look a look at all bad
so e 6 defending the d5 Knight and we
have Knight to b3 now attacking
elephants Queen Queen to a6 offering the
exchange of Queens but if I took the
clients he plays c4 now attacking this
Knight kicking it away and well there
are really nothing
not many squares to go to I mean only
squares night to be for if for example
you jump to e7
well d5 here probably is or D captures
on c5 is pretty pretty terrible for
black you can't really recapture Knight
captures this Knight is well still
pinned it can't move
so after c4 Knight d2 before was played
and this is well also very problematic
as now event took place Knights to be 5
and this comes with a with a pretty big
threat the threat is a Knights to c7 and
also eventually is preparing a 3 and
well if a 3 is played this night has to
move then this other knife will be under
attack if you play Queen to be 7 for
example then a 3 and now this night has
to move and well this is I mean there's
really no where it can go you would have
to play something like 92 a 6 and then
d5 is coming and this is devastating it
captures on d5 now Bishop captures Ang's
after king captures see captures on d5
kicking the night away and well this is
just this is just too powerful for white
knight to e7 now Knight to d6 and white
is all over the place
so after this night the b5 move well
probably the best thing to do here for
black is to capture this a two point
although this isn't really something you
want to do because after you capture
event rick has worked the c3 now
Evangelista threatening rook to a1
trapping the queen but after rook to c3
girl fun would have to play quintet
between two a6 and I'll give up the
exchange with Knight to c6 Queen to b7
and now Knight captures rook and Queen
captures night on a8 and although he
would be down the exchange he would have
this well past a pawn and maybe he could
create some counter play there but get
fun to try to hold on to everything and
after night the b5 get fun played Queen
to a4 and this allows event to end the
game in great style knife to Knight to
c3 now with the tempo on the Queen the
Queen has to move and now the night is
also a defending da two pawns of Queen
has to go back all the way to a6 so
Queen to a6 and now a three and this
this Knight is trapped it has nowhere to
go the Queen just blocked its retreat
paths to a6 but even if it could move it
really can't because this Bishop would
grab the c6 Knight so in this position
girlfriend resigned as he is simply
losing too much material some silly
forcing variation would be nice to d5
but after C captures night a girlfriend
is forced to exchange Queens as the
night is now attacked with the pawn so
after Queen captures and Knight captures
a character Sun d5 Bishop captures on d5
and Bishop to b7 all of this is forcing
black is exactly one piece down so this
is this is unplayable for black
so after this a3 move get fun to resign
the game and Yvonne Chaka
as a has a full point lead and in the
last round event faces the an teaming
the game is drawn and the event truck
wins Linares 1991 with nine and a half
points half a point ahead of world
champion garry kasparov with nine points
so yeah that's the game this is this is
only 18 moves so it's really really a
miniature I know I am interested do you
think that this was home preparation or
was joy was gettin simply being too
adventurous with this game I am
finishing the 1991 win our series
featuring Vasiliy von Schuch and will
probably probably do some other series I
just got this book today this is a an
excellent book
it's the Zurich international chess
tournament of 1953 by David Bronstein
anyone who read this book and went
through it says that it's it's extremely
it's it's it's well there are no words
how valuable this book is it's great for
advanced players and also also for
intermediate and beginners because what
you can really really learn how to find
a plan in the middle game and for those
advanced players you can really get into
the deeper secrets of the position so
yeah that's probably what my next series
will be about thank you all for watching
I would like to I would like to thank
deercucco neck for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here like I said
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon